if you're new to the econ game she'll
find it overwhelming platform that's why
today I'm going to run you through it
what's going on guys my name is every
time you should welcome back to the
channel today we're gonna be talking
about shop fire the pros and the cons of
why you should jump on shop fryer and
really give you a quick tutorial of how
to understand the platform and get to
know behind the scenes dashboard
so if it bothered me for a while now
you've noticed the scenes change a
little bit mate this is just a lot
easier to talk a camera directly and
look at the screen here so we can really
have a good conversation and understand
the platform and understanding tutorial
that we're going through so without
further ado let's jump into shop fire
and get started okay so the best thing
about shop fight is that you get a free
trial like most other platforms out
there they give you about a seven day
free trial actually shop flag gives you
a 14 day free trial to go through and
really get your head around the platform
to try to develop your website and kind
of well realistically hook you in so you
sign up for their platform the first
thing that you're gonna need to do is
create a gmail account I've already gone
ahead and created gmail account in this
tutorial I'm not really going to show
you guys how to create a gmail account
because well I'm hoping that everybody
knows how to create well any email
account it can be outlook Gmail whatever
as long as you have a dedicated email
account for this and for your own
business that's something I recommend
straightaway so let's start with the
store name that we're going to use here
which is last Friday ever at gmail.com
password and store name last Friday ever
and create store so now you just have to
sit back and relax for a little bit
while flag goes through its processing
it here and your stores ready to go in a
matter of seconds you have to fill out
this questionnaire here which really
just runs you through it a couple
different options are you already
selling let's go I'm not selling product
yet for the purpose of this do you have
something to sell yes I have a product
that I'll be launching a few weeks and
what is your current revenue
we're gonna save $0 because we're just
starting a Shopify store are you setting
up the store for a client no we're not
setting up a store for a client we're
setting it up for ourselves
and I'll jump back to you guys in a
minute while I fill out all of this okay
so when you put out the person with
details you can see the main shot by
dashboard this is something that you're
gonna go through and see every single
day when you log into the platform and
your login to your store it's where
everything happens and it's where the
behind-the-scenes happen shot fine does
try to guide you through the process as
best it can
so you can really get through this
without any knowledge of coding or
website design or anything at all so the
first thing I ask you to do is even
select a plan or out of product but the
purpose of this video we're not gonna
select a plan we're gonna just add a
product and really show you guys how to
develop your store and develop a Shopify
thing so let's go add a product and this
is what you see is what you get kind of
platform in the background what we're
going to do is let's say last Friday
ever is a t-shirt clothing brand
dedicated to people who like to travel
or dedicate it to people who want to
design their own cleaning rinse so let's
go
last Friday ever icon shirt the
description is kind of where you're
going to have most of your metadata
information and where Google's going to
help pick up the SEO s and everything
like that so you want your descriptions
to be very descriptive and also very
lengthy but not too lengthy anywhere
between a paragraph maybe to make sure
there's key points so let's talk about
the specs the size is a true to size we
can talk about where it's made and
potentially a partnership with some
charity
and you're just going to go through and
fill out that description and come down
to the bottom and upload an image so
I've gone ahead and just download a
random image off Google I don't own the
rights to this image it's just a random
image on the internet so when you come
down one thing that I do recommend is
adding alt text alt text is again an SEO
or search engine optimization tool which
is going to help your company rake high
on Google you're never going to rank in
the top at the start but if you give it
a few months a few years of working at
it eventually you will become the top
company if you are a successful company
and a successful business so for example
in this one we're gonna go last Friday
ever icon shirt white sizes small medium
large extra-large and done that's
something that's something we stupid but
I do recommend it
pricing well let's go I don't know 29
what they do is flat because I like
round numbers and compare price is
something that you can even do if you're
comparing it to a competitor but if
you're starting your own brand if I use
this as a sales tactic so I compare
price $50 say it's on sale and cost per
item is something for you in the
background say cost $10 it lets you do
jacket margins it lets you calculate
taxes later in the year and charge taxes
on this product is something I keep it
six if you live in Australia you're
gonna need to pay taxes on all your
revenue made on this store if you live
elsewhere well it's up to you do
diligence and really understand what you
need to know about a Shopify store and
being a non econ entrepreneur and ocala
America is very similar to Australian
regulations you have to pay your taxes
which is probably similar everywhere
around the world to be honest you excuse
your barcodes and your parking directory
it's completely up to you if you use it
skews is something that you'll kind of
get used to later on down the track when
you start having more
inventory and you're selling quite a lot
of stock but at the moment if you're
starting small-scale you probably don't
need to add its to because you're gonna
know from the title of your product what
you need to pack and ship quantity is an
interesting one I don't personally use
quantity to track it on Shopify because
it does get a little bit confusing but
if for example you're just selling this
one t-shirt then very simply you can say
you have a hundred of those and do we
want to allow customers to backorder
well no we don't want to this is the
shipping section here which is pretty
self-explanatory again let's say the
shirt weighs about a hundred grams and
then the country of origin well chances
are it's going to come from China we're
being realistic and now this is the HS
coding system which allows you to
provide real time shipping information
if you're in America or in Canada it's
very useful because you can use
companies like DHL whereas in Australia
unfortunately there's not too many
options with this coding system here so
if you're an Australian Shopify store I
completely dismiss this at the start you
don't need to put anything in there at
all your fulfillment services Shopify
later down the track he can obviously
look into filming services which will
basically pack and ship all your orders
for you you just have to let them take
over you do pay them a commission what
percentage or whatever the fees are but
you do obviously pay them to do your job
for you
variance is well very simple if you had
a variant you're gonna have different
sizes in this example small medium large
extra-large sorry
extra large and what we want to do is
you can have different prices safety
extra-large cost a little bit more you
can price them $35 and say we have 25 of
each of these so you inventories split
up 100 total 25 each it really gives you
a freedom to kind of switch things
around and change it up a little bit now
if you do have different colors and
different options of the same shirt or
add variants and let the pictures swap
around this is regular need to know a
little bit of coding and with a quick
search on Google you're gonna be able to
find out how to do that it's relatively
simple I will save that for another
tutorial this is for now just setting on
the basic Shopify store the last thing
you're going to need to look at is this
bottom SEO search and in listing preview
this is going to be exactly what it is
that's how it's gonna look up on Google
when you do eventually shop in the
search results so for this one I will
personally go icon white shirt that
little stroke there last Friday
ever and then your description you want
to write incredible shirt cotton made in
made with reusable resources 100% money
back maybe and then free shipping
something like that just to really draw
the customers in from the Google
homepage straight away keep it very
short keep it very condensed it's
automatically going to take your
description here so I do correctly
recommend changing it so it's a quick
one or two line description making
something you need something useful and
something that the customers are going
to love and click on and that's gonna
make your store stand out
so for products that's all there is to
it you just click click Save product at
the bottom and it's going to take a
little bit of time to save your product
and if you want check out what it's
going to look like customers you click
this little new button yeah and it's
gonna take you to your store here so
this is your first ever product designed
how you like it now you see what I meant
here by the compare prices you're gonna
have $50 of the comparison $30 it's on
sale straightaway you hooked a couple
people because they love things that are
on sale you have to be cautious with
sales and discount
obviously you don't want your customers
to get a custom which is getting cheaper
and cheaper items a great picture I
found shot lasers why make these zooms
and to your product here so make sure
your pictures are high-res there's no
dirt dust things like that on your
images but that is basically what your
product is going to look like at the
moment and it's going request that a
customer selects a size so again if we
go to the extra-large you're gonna see
the price changes you don't have to
change it according to size obviously
but however if you're getting into with
Drupal Excel or something there is a
good chance that this is gonna cost more
and then it's again up to you if you
want to charge more for that item so
let's go back to our Shopify home and
we've added our first product which is
fantastic and the next step here is to
customize your theme
now before we customize our theme I'm
gonna run through this little sidebar
here so your sidebar is pretty
self-explanatory
when you go to orders this is where all
your orders are going to come up at the
moment we don't have any
now obviously the store's not liable
either so it's asking you to select a
plan if you're just on trial mode it's
not gonna allow you to sell any products
it's just gonna be a trial so don't
think you can get 14 days brave for
trying to avoid the payment plan one
thing that's very important and critical
wants to start running your store is
they've banned and check out this is
something that's really powerful with
retargeting ads and email marketing
campaigns and Google Facebook pixels
Google pixels and just really trying to
get those people that ever had a
split-second decision or been
interrupted during an abandoned car
process walked away and forgotten about
your store so when they come to Facebook
tomorrow Instagram tomorrow hopefully
they come back and they're going to see
that ad and potentially you're gonna be
able to recover that sale so that's why
abandon checkout is a very useful
section of this sidebar
products is your next option on the
sidebar which is pretty self-explanatory
if you do need to edit any products that
you've created change prices change to
use anything like that you can edit them
from this spot here so if you click into
the same product that we just created a
minute ago you're gonna see everything
the same and you're gonna be able to
adjust it
you need to on the right hand side here
is something I didn't go through and
that's the product type the vendor or
the collection and tags so if you have a
different collection for example this is
the last Friday icon collection and then
you have the first Friday Nikon
collection I don't know you can have
different collections for different
things you're able to create collections
and group these items together which
makes it easier for customers to go oh I
want an icon shirt or I want to first
fry their shirt and they can just filter
by those same thing with the tags if you
create tags you can go a white/black
design here and just a little tags that
people might be searching in that
filters I wouldn't go overboard they
don't help with any SEO s or anything
like that so realistically you don't
even need them if you don't want to and
that's basically it with that adjustment
section there the one thing that I have
had actually really helpful is the
duplicate top so if you're creating an
identical product maybe with just a
different variants very similar
description you just duplicate the item
don't duplicate the images and rename
and at the top and you'll be able to get
product out a lot quicker so along the
products section here you're gonna have
transfers if you have different
locations for your products generally
you're probably gonna have most of you
stock in one place if not drop shipping
inventory again managing your inventory
understanding how many of each item you
have left this is very useful if you do
start running low you can really start
tracking these one by one and maybe
reducing them just to make sure you
don't run out and have to email
customers and be like hey look sorry
guys right now that's always a bad email
to receive from a company collections
again something I was just talking about
there you can create different
collections here so let's go ahead and
create the last Friday collection
collection and let's say that this
collection is all about adventure
weekends I don't know something like
that obviously if this is your store put
a lot more time and effort into these
creative
at the moment this is just a quick
tutorial okay so there's one error
subtext in the product a given equal to
I didn't change this so down because
it's automatically populated you want to
make sure that the product tag is equal
to last Friday ever and then we can save
that and just to demonstrate how that
actually works is if we go back into all
our products go to the last Friday if I
icon shirt last Friday Emma and now if
we save that change and scroll down to
collections hopefully we're gonna have
one product automatically added to that
bear so now you're able to create
different sections in your website to be
able to sell different categories and
let people shop a lot easier you can
also do this with men's and women's and
kids things like that if you really want
to get into it
gift cards is the last option here
gift cards is on a more advanced shot
for I plan you can't get it on the basic
one however just a pro tip if you're
looking to use after pay you can't
actually use gift cards and are to pay
at the same time so you don't really
need an advanced shot flight theme if
you're looking to use are to pay from
the get going or if you don't need your
cards analytics going down the section a
bit more gives you a good rundown of
your store it's very similar to Google
Analytics I would also suggest
implementing Google Analytics into your
Shopify store so you have the greater
data from Google and not just the basics
you get from sure why
so shop fire will give you some generic
statistics obviously the stores
non-existent so we have no statistics
marketing is a tab I don't use because
obviously if you're running a store you
really want to be running your own
marketing you don't want to let Shopify
take over and in my personal opinion
you're gonna be wasting a little bit of
your money here Shopify does have a good
generic marketing plan but obviously if
you can understand Facebook Ads
Instagram ads it's a lot better but you
go ahead and do that instead of
marketing through this platform discount
codes is where you create a discount
code for
customers maybe you found that
ambassador to represent your brand and
you want to set them up with a discount
code so they can give them to our
followers so let's say John John ten
that use the discount code it's gonna
get them ten percent off everything you
can have a fixed amount you can give
them free shipping or you can do a buy X
get Y it's completely up to you how you
set these discount codes up but each
variant here is exactly the same running
down a little bit further it applies to
entire water specific collection
specific products here you can make sure
that you're only selling this disc a
code potentially to the men's products
and women's products to whatever you
need it to and you can also limit the
purchase amount and a minimum quantity
of items so for example if you already
have a massive sale on and most of your
items have dropped under $20 and you
can't give a further discount here
because you've been losing money
you set a minimum purchase amount of
$25.00 for example that way you're set
you don't have to worry about it and you
won't be losing money on anything there
that's below $25.00 now something that I
like to add is limit one per customer so
you don't have customers coming back and
using the same discount code over and
over again if it is an ambassador
however it potentially good to antique
that because they do like to have
customers returning and using their same
code and it really makes sure that
ambassador is doing their job and really
helping new boost your brand but you can
set a limit in total so say you've got
10 maximum on his discount code first 10
people to use it get 10% off things like
that you can really do quite a lot of
things here but it is a very simple
thing to setup you just run through it
follow the instructions and once you've
setup
it's what matically done for you there's
nothing more you have to do you can set
up automatic codes as well which runs
through this exact same system as codes
it just means your customers don't have
to type in a code of the checkout it
potentially saves their money but it
loses money for you at the same time so
as the catch 22 apps here is one of the
most powerful sections each on fire
and it is the reason why I recommend
shelf life or any common entrepreneur in
2019 or ever any other store there's so
many different apps created for Shopify
basically you can get different shipping
app different marketing apps different
pop-ups printers anything that you can
think of Shopify or some developer has
created an app for this and it's
something that if you add a select
amount of apps don't go overboard you
can actually have your website even more
so for example one of my favorite apps
is the Facebook Messenger app so they
don't have to contact you by email they
can send you a Facebook message straight
away and most the time everybody's got
their phone out so you can quickly reply
your customers they're not waiting
around for hours forgetting about your
store potentially losing that sale so
Apps is 100% the biggest Pro Shop right
in my personal opinion okay so going
back to the store the last thing you're
gonna see is your sales channels and at
the moment we only have an online store
however you can have a present store
different Facebook Instagram stores and
you can have a wish store for example if
you're selling some product like that
which really gives you the flexibility
but because we've just started out the
only thing we have here is the online
store so at the moment our website if we
go customized website we're gonna see
what our website looks like at the
moment it's basically a generic bland
website that we get to edit and promote
the best we can
Shopify kind of limits you to the home
page in a sense but this is the most
flexible editing you get along the way
you don't really get to edit all the
pages behind the scenes in the same
fashion that you do with weeks and
Squarespace but that's why shot if I run
so smoothly because everything behind
the scenes is already done it's very
fluid and it's very well done so there's
no issues whereas when you go on sites
like Wix and potentially Squarespace in
my opinion you start messing around with
too many things you end up with a lot of
problems later down the track and that's
how you're not losing customers so if we
want to edit anything on this shop by
theme we can use this side panel down
the left it is very self-explanatory
is very basic so it's not going to take
too hard or too long for us to figure it
out
so the main generic image if we select
an image let's go to three images
because I haven't downloaded anything
men's fashion let's go the bloke on a
bike and yeah that looks great on our
store let's select that image we want to
go with the heading last Friday a bar no
more work weeks just adventure so maybe
that's the slogan of your store maybe
that's what you want people to see first
potentially you want that to be
something different but for the time
being we'll just stick with that and
then you go back here and you can go
through the different sections and do
similar things so if featured products
feature collections so it can be your
home page let's change it to our last
Friday over collection and then that
shirt pops up so all of a sudden just
you store your own page your landing
page whatever you wanna call it is
starting to create its own theme and
starting to come together you can add
different sections potentially a blog
post once you click on it it shows you
what a blog post might look like or for
example you want to add a logo list if
you're a media company or production
company and you've worked with big
brands like mercedes-benz Nike yet
anything like that maybe you've worked
with big companies that's something
that's a great selling point and
potentially you want to add that into
your website so everybody else can see
that you've done a good job you've
worked with these other companies and
you rep really the easiest way because
this is such an important feature
potentially for your company you can
just click and drag it to wherever you
want on your website so all of a sudden
last Friday ever logo released and as
people scroll they're gonna
your website more and more about who you
are and the rest of the homepage is
actually you develop in the same way so
I'm not going to go through much more of
that because it's just going to be very
repetitive we're gonna jump into theme
settings here very quickly lets you
customize all the colors of everything
on your store so sale prices that we
don't want it to be blue we potentially
want them to do red yep
primary colors we can have them in black
and if we scroll down there we go we see
that the sale price has changed just for
convenience to show you guys blue red
pretty self-explanatory all these fields
you can adjust and watch how you store
changes this is something that you're
gonna have to pay attention to in the
future different colors and different
themes can actually help me generate
more sales and generate different
markets and different audiences so for
example you have a blue very calming
color that maybe your store is all about
the ocean and looking to promote mindful
meditation or something like that
if you stores or injure empowering
there's a lot of psychology behind
colors something that you can easily
look up on Google and something I do
recommend you take quickl go before you
go ahead and select all your different
colors of you store ok so let's say
we've completed our website that's all
done let's go back to Shopify well when
it's cancer that and saving our changes
first and then go back shop fire so by
going back Shopify just click the purple
shopping cart in the top left corner and
it takes you back to your home page so
now that our theme started to develop
we'll go back to home with other
products with customized our theme we
want to add a domain so I won't go
through this fully because obviously it
does cost a little bit of money to set
up a domain and I'm not actually going
to be running this store ever let's say
I don't have a domain
I want to buy a new domain you can buy
from shop by itself or you can go to
sites like GoDaddy crazy domains dirt
cheap domains anything like that and
connect it to your store
ok so the one last thing I want to go
through with you guys is in the online
store and the navigation section the
menu headers up the top and the footer
menu down the bottom as well so in the
main menu you can add different custom
menu options for example you can have
men's which links the collection maybe
and the last Friday collection might be
your men's items then we can do the same
thing down the bottom for women's and at
the moment I haven't created anything
but let's say you've created the home
page is your women's collection for the
purposes of this and you can create that
there and will delete catalog because we
don't need that one at the moment and
home you can keep if you like you don't
have to save the menu here so when you
go back into your online store and go
customize once again takes a little bit
of time to boot up but you're gonna see
at the top in your menu you're gonna
home men's and women's so if we click
men's you're gonna see that one product
we created and he click women's it's
probably gonna take you back to the home
page or the Home Collection which we
have nothing in but basically that's how
you create new header menus at the top
now there is a lot to go through and
shop fire different settings and themes
you can select different themes so for
example we can explore the three themes
that might be more suited to your store
so potentially it's a t-shirt brand and
beauty brand is selling some apple style
white background products maybe you just
like bigger pictures and overviews and
things like that but you do have a
little bit of a choice for different
free themes which is gonna basically
redefine how your homepage looks like
you can take a look into this you can
see this one for you
as two different styles the bone and the
toy one of these styles may be more
suited to your store it might not but
you do also have lots of different paid
themes as well these paid themes are
quite expensive and in my personal
opinion don't make that much of a
difference when you're starting out when
you do get a little bit down the track
it may be more worthwhile looking into
these paid themes or potentially even
hiring a developer if you don't know
enough about coding but this is where
your paid themes really kind of stay
stand out from the crowd and let you
create something a little bit different
so for example this label theme is very
different to all the others you're able
to view a demo of the site as well so
you can really get a feel for what it
looks like
so we've just landed on this record you
scroll down it's got really nice clean
lines very minimalistic
to be honest you can probably create
this very similar kind of layout by
adding different sections to your thing
that you have it which is a debut theme
but hey look you don't have the time
it's potentially an option that you're
able to just customize one of these
themes it might be a bit quicker take
into consideration that when you do buy
a new theme where you duplicate your
theme that all the changes you've made
to your theme aren't going to be
automatically apply to this so all these
pictures that you see you in the screen
now are going to be completely different
you're not going to have for example the
guy on the back sitting there first
picture you're going to have the record
dryer it's all going to be relative to
the theme and you're gonna basically
have to start from scratch again so yeah
there's lots of different themes that
you can choose from again this one here
is 160 dollars which again I don't
recommend really if you're just starting
out they go to 180 and upwards some of
them are actually really really good
worth looking into and great to sort by
different categories so at the moment
let's say were running a clothing and
fashion store it gives you the themes
that have been designed for clothing in
fashion for example is broadcast one
looks very minimalistic looks very good
but at the same time this has been
photoshopped edited and designed in a
way to actually stand out and look the
best if you just chuck two different
images on here it's not gonna look as
good so be very mindful with the themes
that you select and you have a play
around with the debut think Fame cursed
or there any of the other free themes
and really get an understanding of how
Shopify works before you potentially go
out and buy a - Herald theme that's only
slightly different and may or may not
increase your conversion rate that's
pretty much it guys that's a basic well
half an hour 40 minute run-through of
what a potential Shopify theme may look
like for you it's a very basic tutorial
there is so much to go through and if
you do like it make sure you smash that
subscribe button and let me know that
you enjoyed this video I want to see
more of them and if you do I'll
potentially go down break shop right
into a lot more detail and give you guys
a lot more information so you can really
understand a platform and go ahead and
start your new store
if you need to the channel you probably
haven't if you're new to the channel I
post in your econ related video every
Monday it's either about tech econ
different things that are going to help
you along your econ journey and just
general entrepreneur lifestyle if you're
new to the channel I post a new video
every Monday about a different tech and
different econ related videos if you're
new to the channel I post a new video
every single Monday in relation to
different econ advice if you're new to
the channel I post a new video every
Monday that you might find helpful
they're all about becoming at lunch
Panora
in 2019 and different tech related
videos so if any of this interests you
or if this video you found past there
make sure you smash that subscribe
button and I'll see you next Monday